[Music]
when most people think of pollen they
probably think of allergies and runny
noses while pollen may be the source of
our sneezes it's also the source of our
food
Pollan contains sperm
which fertilizes plants allowing them to
reproduce
what ends up on our dinner plates begins
when a pollen grain lands on a plant
stigma
soon after the pollen grain germinates
into a pollen tube which is a true hero
of our story the pollen tube is an
incredible single cell focused entirely
on delivering to sperm cells to the
plants of Ewell
to arrive at the ovule the pollen tube
undergoes tip growth which is a form of
unidirectional cell growth
this is a rather exceptional process
considering that the cell can grow over
a thousand times its original length in
just a few hours in fact pollen tubes
are the fastest recording extending
cells after the pollen tube has
travelled the entire length of the plant
style it arrives at the ovule which
contains the egg and central cell once
here the pollen tube bursts and releases
the two sperm cells for a process called
double fertilization one of the sperm
fuses with the egg creating the embryo
that will become the new plant the other
sperm fuses with the central cell which
develops into the endosperm a
nutrient-rich tissue that supports the
development of the embryo this is what
we eventually will eat wheat endosperm
is ground into flour for bread and the
endosperm of corn are the kernels that
we eat directly off the cob
these products are global food staples
and we depend heavily on them in order
to feed our planet's growing population
as we've seen the growth of the pollen
tube transports a sperm to the plants
ovule where fertilization occurs
fertilization allows a plant whether
it's corn wheat or another crop to start
growing
so the success of the pollen tubes
journey from stigma to ovule is
essential for our food supply system if
this cellular journey goes wrong we
cannot produce major crops such as corn
rice wheat and tomatoes the growth of
the pollen tube is temperature sensitive
so climate change poses a great risk to
our food supply out of all plant cells
pollen tubes are the most temperature
sensitive in fact a pollen tube that is
fully functional at a certain
temperature might be unable to locate
the ovule at a temperature only a few
degrees higher resulting in a completely
sterile plant
for instance experiments have shown that
the pollen tubes of corn and wheat grown
at 30 degrees Celsius 86 degrees
Fahrenheit were unable to successfully
complete double fertilization climate
scientists predicted that global
temperatures may rise between two and
six degrees Celsius by the year 2100
so in many places where corn and wheat
are grown the threshold temperature of
30 degrees Celsius will likely be
crossed by the end of the century this
puts us at risk of losing some of our
staple foods so what can we do to
protect our food supply one solution
would be to halt climate change by
greatly reducing our admission of
greenhouse gases such as carbon dioxide
however at this point climate change has
progressed so far that it may not be
possible to save our crops instead
scientists are working to engineer
thermo tolerant crops
to do this more research needs to be
done to understand how each step of the
pollen tube journey could be engineered
to be more heat-resistant
so the next time you sneeze or eat a
piece of pizza be sure to think about
the mighty pollen tube and the
scientists working hard to protect its
incredible journey
[Music]